the continuing build up at Cam Ranh Bay
promises to make this port one of the
largest and busiest in the world port
construction at the bay did not actually
begin until June of 1965 three months
after a coastal survey determined its
potential as a major harbour soon after
men of the 35th engineering group which
began initial construction were joined
by ordinance headquarters quartermaster
and transportation units by november of
last year the quartermaster Depot was
activated and began accepting
requisitions from kenyon natrang and
Saigon today a data processing facility
is nearing completion which will enable
much more efficient inventory control
another important project currently
underway by the 87th engineers is the
building of a new causeway to the
ammunition dump in anticipation of the
build-up yet to come more construction
equipment has been concentrated at Cam
Ranh Bay than there has ever been
anywhere else in Southeast Asia
during August military civic action
programs were in full swing throughout
Vietnam several activities took place in
the province of Phu Yen a medical team
arrives at thuy war a village 360
kilometers northeast of Saigon patients
are treated and supplied with medicine
instructions for its use are usually
given in sign language when necessary
injections help underfed youngsters
fight off native ills bad teeth are a
recurrent problem many must be polled
toothbrushes disinfectants medical
literature and clothing are handed out
this is all part of our program of
teaching personal hygiene the team stays
in the village until the last patient
has been treated only then do they
return to base not far away are the
headquarters of the first Brigade 100
first division on 27 August fire breaks
out in a village across from the base a
bucket squad is quickly organized by the
military police and additional
firefighting equipment is supplied by an
engineering company water arrives in
tank cars and soon the villagers health
by the American soldiers have the fire
under control 24 huts are burned to the
ground and 28 families lose everything
they own except the clothes on their
backs still no lives are lost and thanks
to quick action by the MPS and engineers
most of the village is saved no chances
are taken on the fire breaking out again
the wreckage is cleared away and every
ember is thoroughly drenched with water
as the last spark goes out our men go
back to their camp and the villagers
begin to rebuild
only a few kilometers away is the hamlet
of war he civ here a school formerly
used as a headquarters by VC terrorists
is repaired on the roof volunteers from
the 100 first airborne helped the
workers and protect them against
possible sniper fire these holes have
been made by grenades while small arms
fire has caused most of the damage to
the walls and the windows as the
children watch the work continues roof
tiles are put into place outside our men
stand guard while inside desks are
repaired and the classroom is put back
in order helping whenever they can
members of the 100 first airborne
division are doing their share in the
civic action program
efforts by the 300 men headquarters
Australian force to aid the Vietnamese
people are gaining support the unit
recently began to help a small orphanage
in Saigon and when word of their
activities reached Australia companies
and individuals generously began to send
needed supplies of food and clothing on
September 3rd members of the unit
arrived at the orphanage to deliver the
latest shipment cartons of baby food and
sugar the orphaned children range from
only a few days old 23 years of age many
formerly suffered from malnutrition and
body sores but now Australian Medical
Officer Captain John Raftery and a
Vietnamese doctor have begun regular
medical visits in addition to their
direct benefits civic action programs
such as this are playing an increasingly
important role in combating Viet Cong
propaganda
45 generals gather in Seoul on August
thirteenth for the commanding generals
fourth Invitational shooting match the
five event program between general
officers and Colonels of the republic of
korea and US Army's was held at the
picturesque korean military academy
range bordered by pine studded slopes
team positions on the morning long card
are decided by lot host for the match
was Gerald whitey Beach commander of the
8th US Army at last year's meet the
first ROK army walked off with the top
prize in the star-studded field which
has been dominated annually by Koreans
and their firearms teams take their
places of the firing line for the three
rifle events the carbine m 1 and m 14
the last two events were shot with 38
and 45 caliber pistols at a distance of
twenty-five yards it was their accuracy
with these sidearms that brought the
second ROK army to the forefront beating
out general beaches eighth army
headquarters team 345 2 335 after
tabulation of the scores and a break for
lunch general Beach presented the
individual awards and to Lieutenant
General young one POC commanding general
and captain of a second ROK army the
team plaque for the winning entry
at Lake kimse Germany a skydiving team
from a third support Brigade known as
the sky Eagles is about to give a water
landing jump exhibition before boarding
there h 34 helicopter members of the
jump team are checked out by First
Sergeant William Richey headquarters
company 35th supply service this is how
the lake resort located 40 miles south
of Munich looks on a clear September day
the sky Eagles will soon be joining the
sailing craft in the lake first man out
is sergeant Ritchie parachuting into
water is not easy because it is
unusually difficult to judge the
distance and speed at which the jumper
is falling he is followed by first
lieutenant George Sobel of the 790 third
MP Battalion who free falls for an
interminable time before pulling the
ripcord
but the sky Eagles know their job
without exception they land on target
wet but happy with their success
Warren Dorf Germany 6 September a US
team from Fort Sam Houston Texas is
representing the Armed Forces of the
United States in the annual council
international do sport militare scism
modern pentathlon championships this
year's meet is being hosted by West
Germany crack military teams from ten
european countries and the United States
are competing in the five event
championships which include horseback
riding fencing pistol shooting swimming
and a four thousand meter cross-country
run each competitor must complete all
five events before he can qualify for
individual and team standings the 5,000
meter steeplechase course has 30 jumps
taking the hurdles his specialist
william matheson of the US team despite
a clean ride and eleven second penalty
relegates him to 16th place in this
event interest in the system neat has
been high since modern pentathlon made
its official debut during the nineteen
twelve olympics at that time general
george s patton then lieutenant finished
fifth overall in the individual
standings fencing is conducted under
international rules using electrical
contact controls each man must first
compete against each member of his own
team before being matched against
members of other teams in this event
specialist Matheson leads the US
contingent as he placed eighth among the
26 competitors for the pistol shoot
lieutenant Donald wall I'm and alternate
blackens his sights and discuss a
strategy with a team manager lieutenant
colonel Emmett see Townsend in this
event on the 25 meter pistol range
specialist Matheson comes through again
to take third place in the scoring
swimming events occupy the fourth day of
the competition
in the 300-meter swim Lieutenant James
coots cuts through the water to a fast
paced win for the US team lieutenant
coots proudly takes his place of honor
on the winter stand the final event of
the meet the four thousand meter
cross-country run gets underway for the
US with lieutenant coots running against
the clock specialist Larsen number eight
gets his top off and starts down the
long trail specialist Matheson is the
third and last member of the team to
leave the course is laid out over rugged
and varied terrain
specialist Larson with a time of 12 40.7
takes first place on the winners stand
specialist Larson proudly accepts his
prize on behalf of the US team then
stands at attention as the American flag
is raised signifying a first-place
victory in the event at formal
ceremonies held in the streets of
warendorf the US team has awarded second
place behind Italy in the overall
competition
at two-week intervals throughout the
year the advanced individual training
brigade AIT Fort Dix New Jersey holds an
orientation on the weapons of the
infantry designed to give new recruits
and introduction to the weapons and
their capabilities the demonstrations
are popular with the public who turn out
in large numbers to see the show among
the weapons demonstrated is the caliber
45 pistol the m14 a2 equipped with an
automatic capability bipod legs to hand
grips and a flash compensator this
weapon replaces the VAR the m16 rifle is
gaining popularity among troops in
Vietnam it permits the launching of
grenades without supplementary
attachments
the m79 grenade launcher firing a
40-millimeter projectile is known as the
infantryman's hip pocket artillery the
m79 is designed to furnish the squad
with grenade protection between the
maximum distance a man can throw a
grenade and the minimum Rangers a mortar
can be fired the m60 machine gun has a
cyclic rate of fire of 550 rounds per
minute and with its quick-change barrel
offers a great advantage over the old
caliber 30 machine gun the m60 can be
handheld mounted on a bipod or tripod
the 50 caliber machine gun has a semi as
well as full automatic capability when
equipped with a telescopic sight it may
be used as a sniper weapon the 90
millimeter recoilless rifle replaces the
3.5 rocket launcher as an anti-tank
weapon upon impact the round burns its
way through the tank hull and the molten
metal then ricochets killing the crew it
can be fired from the monopod or from
the shoulder the 10 6 millimeter
recoilless rifle is the company's
long-range anti-tank weapon the 81
millimeter mortar is a widely used
weapon and is normally placed in support
of the rifle company
for spectators and recruits alike a good
show
you